n'est pas question de fêter noël sans
livres sous le sapin vous vous en doutez
bien et tiphaine faille fera forcément
des idées puisque vous êtes agréé par le
père noël
des idées cadeaux pour les ados et les
enfants dès 6 ans typhaine oui et j'ai
décidé de vous proposer uniquement des
livres qui font gréve et un cette année
un positive attitude
alors celui ci c'est un livre
d'alexandre jardin et fred muletiers
publié par gautier languereau elle
s'appelle le petit du bialé je vous
propose de partir à la rencontre de ce
petit animal poilus qui fait rire les
plaintes et qui sait parler aux hommes
ils habitent dans une île du pacifique
et il vivait bien tranquille avant qu'un
anglais décide de partir en exploration
pour l'étudier alors vous allez le voir
tout ne va pas très bien se passer mais
heureusement deux enfants mary et
robinson vont essayer de le protéger
alors les dessins sont magnifiques
féerique et vraiment c'est tout un
univers qui s'ouvre aux jeunes lecteurs
en ouvrant ce livre c'est un magnifique
conte de noël qui prônait le respect de
la nature
j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé je les
tester sur mes enfants je le recommande
c'est un joli cadeau de noël à glisser
sous le sapin
super un joli conte de noël sans neige
signé par le romancier alexandre jardin
on va rester dans le bestiaire
fantastique avec de drôles d'animaux je
sais pas s'ils ont des poils cela mais
après les oublis galles semble qu'ils
aient une licorne c'est ça je fais je
fais bien la licorne
mais je suis sûr que vous adorez les
lucarnes pascal tout le monde aime les
licornes
avec ce livre la dame à la licorne de
béatrice fontanel et vanessa hié publié
chez celles jeunesse et bien vous allez
plonger dans la tapisserie la célèbre
tapisserie et de la renaissance
l'histoire est simple le seigneur et ses
chevaliers ravage tout sur leur passage
à chaque fois qu'il passe en forêt mais
en général ils ne voient pas un les
faits et les animaux féerique qu'il
dérange sauf qu'un jour le seigneur
aperçoit la licorne et décide de la
prendre en chasse pour s'approprier et
bien les pouvoirs de sa corne
alors ce livre est vraiment magnifique
les illustres
a sion sont très belle dans l'esprit de
la renaissance et s'inspire en fait des
symboles des tapisseries
alors le petit plus c'est que vous
verrez à la fin des pages pédagogie pour
vous expliquer tous ses symboles c'est
donc un livre féerique éducatif et
artistique
un grand format comme je les aime mais
moi j'adore les licornes en plus parce
que c'est le symbole de l'innocence de
la pureté et de l'ecosse je refais le
likoud pour la peine allez vous nous
avez promis du rêve
tout le monde ne rêve pas quand même
d'être chevallier licorne ou fait vous
êtes peut-être autre chose pour nous et
bien j'ai du rêve sur mesure avec le
ciné rêve d n'diaye roland garrigues et
catherine duval c'est une bande dessinée
chez casterman parce que les enfants
adorent les bandes dessinées vous le
savez imaginez que vous ayez des
pouvoirs magiques et en reste dans la
magie et vous décidé de monter un projet
un peu fou
le ciné rêve ça permet de vivre un rêve
sur mesure un rêve dont vous êtes le
héros pendant quelques minutes
comme dans un cinéma et bien le petit
augustin va tester sauf que ce n'était
pas tout à fait au point
alors c'est une bande dessinée qui
plaira aux enfants à partir de 8 ans
vraiment je vous la conseille ans et
pour tous les fans de mortal adèle
anatole la tuile ou 109 rue des soupirs
c'est à offrir les yeux fermés voilà les
dessins sont magnifiques mais attention
je vous préviens tout de suite ça rend
accro et il y aura un tome 2 parfait
parfait parfait propos de magie je
précise que bientôt anaëlle le magicien
viendra donner des cours aux enfants ça
sera pour l'année prochaine c'est une
des surprises que nous vous avons
réservé propos de surprises vous en avez
une toute dernière une dernière idée
cadeau pour les ados avec un roman
réédité cette année par une toute petite
maison d'édition c'est monsieur tout
seul aventure c'est cet effet oui c'est
une maison d'édition qui gagne à être
connu et qui aiment rééditer des textes
anciens
alors en parlant de textes anciens là
j'y suis bien ce texte date de 1908 ça
s'appelle anne de green games et ça a
été écrit par la canadienne lucy maud
montgomery
pourquoi je vous en parle déjà parce que
c'est un livre magnifique un qui donne
immédiatement envie
de l'ouvrir et l'histoire est absolument
génial c'est un classique de la
littérature nord américaine ça s'est
vendu à 60 millions d'exemplaires
imaginer comme vingt mille lieues sous
les mers en gros mais ici c'est méconnu
c'est l'histoire d'une petite orpheline
de 11 ans and qui arrive chez un couple
de frères et soeurs des fermiers de
l'île du prince édouard qui voulait
adopter un garçon pour aider à la ferme
alors quand ils la voient débarquer
évidemment ils ne le font pas le
meilleur accueil
mais elle va réussir à se faire aimer
alors qu'elle et gaffeuse et qu'elle est
très excentrique vraiment c'est le livre
feel good de cet hiver c'est à partir du
collège disons la quatrième c'est pour
les adolescents c'est pour les adultes
je vous le recommande
ça a été hyper bien reçu en france et si
jamais je n'ai pas réussi à vous
convaincre sachez que mark twain a écrit
que c'était kahn était l'enfant la plus
attachante la plus émouvante et la plus
délicieuse depuis l'immortel alice alors
comparer une héroïne à alice au pays des
merveilles c'est quand même pas rien
ouais moi j'ai noté un ses fils good
c'est un livre qui redonne le moral à
tous ont atteint l'année avec le sourire
on attend mieux merci pour votre joli
sourire et rendez vous l'année prochaine
typhaine et bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
avec un tout petit peu d'avancé déjà
prévu des cadeaux à glisser sous le
sapin en plus de livres non je commence
à y réfléchir mais y aura quand même des
livres
j'ai quelques petites idées mois d'ici
la fin de l'émission à bientôt iphone
merci on retrouve évidemment cette
chronique sur les réseaux sociaux
forcément